bonsoir nous sommes le 19 mars nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu sur TVfil 78 en
direct toujours des 18 heures une fois
de plus il sera principalement en
question des élections municipales avec
ce premier tour et du scrutin qui
approche mais tout d'abord un mot
concernant cette journée anniversaire le
19 mars 1962 était ordonné à un cesser
le feu en Algérie la veille 18 mars
était signée les accords d'Évian qui
mettaient fin à 8 ans de guerre et
ouvrait la voix à l'indépendance de ce
pays plusieurs communes ont célébré
cette journée du souvenir pour les
victimes de la guerre en Algérie à La
Verrière comme ici ou encore à Trappes
un rendez-vous qui suscite cependant la
polémique car certains considèrent que
des massacres ont continué après le 19
mars 62 notamment de harkis et
combattants musulmans engagés aux côtés
des Français nous parlons d'orientation
scolaire à présent c'est le sujet qui
préoccupe famille et lycéens
actuellement demain à minuit les
demandes d'inscription sur le site
internet APB admission post-bac seront
close d'où l'importance de ne pas se
tromper de voix depuis quelques années
ce sont des entreprises privées un petit
guide les élèves elles exercent
maintenant une activité jusque la
réservée aux conseillers d'orientation
psychologues des collèges et des lycées
Sabrina chichini Elodie moines se sont
rendus à Versailles dans une de ces
nouvelles agences spécialisées
l'orientation une formalité pour les uns
un casse-tête pour les autres Sonia
taradal l'a bien compris il y a un an
cet ancienne salariée de Saint-Gobain
titulaire d'un CAPES d'espagnol s'est
lancé dans le coaching d'orientation
privée nous on oriente les élèves depuis
la classe de 3e jusqu'à jusqu'aux études
supérieures l'avantage aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on permet aux élèves d'accéder à
beaucoup de domaines d'études quel que
soit leur filière de formation la seule
chose c'est qu'on leur dit pas comment y
accéder
correctement ou le ou le plus simplement
possible pour certains son bac en poche
Camille décide d'étudier la médiation
culturelle trois ans plus tard elle se
rend compte qu'elle s'est trompée elle
frappe alors à la porte du coach
je suis allée pour tout ce que j'avais
un coup de coeur et que c'était une
formation qui je pensais pouvait me
convenir mais en fait on n'a pas
aiguillé dans mes choix la jeune femme
souhaite désormais s'orienter vers des
études de graphisme lors des entretiens
avec sa conseillère elle a été déroutée
par le nombre de formations possibles
je vais tu mets la licence dans la elle
est en terminale scientifique il y a un
an elle a des doutes quant à son avenir
professionnel lors des séances de
coaching elle confirme son appétence
pour le commerce aujourd'hui Sonia
taradement de ses vœux sur le site
admission post-bac
certaines familles ils trouvent leur
compte les Conseillers d'Orientation
Psychologue et mettent quelques réserves
quand au développement du coaching privé
en ligne de mire la formation des coachs
n'importe qui et en fait n'importe
quelle étude avant peut se nommer
coachlène c'est que tout jeune ne peut
pas s'offrir les services d'un coaching
privé ici à Versailles les tarifs du
coaching varient entre 330 et 580 euros
pour 4h d'entretien des sommes que
certains sont prêts à payer pour être
rassurés sur leur choix
dans l'actualité de ce 19 mars la
campagne municipale qui touche à sa fin
dans une ambiance parfois très tendue à
Magny-les-Hameaux par exemple le
socialiste Bertrand Houillon annonce
avoir déposé une plainte après la
vandalisation de ses panneaux électoraux
des tags où l'on peut lire fondational
FN sont venus recouvrir ses affiches à
La Verrière vandalisation aussi les
affiches du divers droites Nicolas
Dainville des affiches arrachés et là
aussi une plante déposée et puis à
Élancourt le candidat indépendant
Christian Nicole nous informe avoir été
victime d'un piratage de sa boîte mail
ces derniers jours afin selon lui de
l'effrayer avant le premier tour
nous poursuivons plus sereinement notre
série de portraits de candidats dans les
Yvelines 2 derniers reportage à
découvrir ce soir à Trappes tout d'abord
ou deux listes de dernière minute sont
venues s'ajouter à celle mener par le
maire sortant socialiste avec Guy
Malandain le communique Luc Miserey
communiste Luc Miserey ou encore le
divers droites Othman Nasro 5 listes
donc au final pour une ville où le maire
sortant a plutôt l'habitude de
l'emporter assez largement à l'issue du
vote sera-t-elle différente cette année
Catherine zulato
5 listes seront proposés aux électeurs
trappistes dimanche 23 mars parmi ces
candidats le maire sortant le socialiste
Guy Malandain en 1995 il devient mère
adjoint de la commune avant d'en prendre
la tête sans discontinuer depuis 2001
une passion une passion qui le pousse à
76 ans à se relancer dans la campagne
avec une équipe renouvelée à moitié et
dans laquelle on retrouve notamment
Sandrine Grandgambe la première
secrétaire de la fédération PS des
Yvelines et Benoît Hamon ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire député
de la circonscription depuis juin 2012
pour cette campagne Guy Malandain se
fixe comme principal priorité la
parentalité la famille et l'éducation
l'enfant doit être pris de la maternelle
jusqu'au lycée peut-être même après mais
enfin ici sur le territoire de Trappes
jusqu'au lycée deuxième axe le
développement économique par exemple 5
hectares de la future ZAC aérostats
seront réservés à l'artisanat enfin
poursuivre et terminer la rénovation
urbaine
gérer ce qui a été fait parce que rien
ne serait pire que avoir investi les
sommes qu'on investit je pense surtout
au logement social quoi et puis des
secteurs qui nous qui n'ont pas été
traités je pense au secteur de Védrines
qui a besoin de renouveau je pense je
pense à Camus je pense à la Cité
nouvelle
face à lui le candidat divers droites
Hotman nasru à 27 ans ce chef
d'entreprise s'est engagé il y a deux
ans au sein du collectif trap citoyen
c'est une ville très attachante dans
laquelle il y a il y a beaucoup à faire
et aujourd'hui il y a un tas de sujets
qui ne sont pas gérés donc quand on s'en
rend compte quand on se quand on veut
s'engager faire bouger les choses au
bout d'un moment on se rend compte que
c'est le seul moyen c'est d'aller sur le
terrain politique sur le terrain
politique
othmann Nasro pour la première fois
candidat veut mettre l'accent sur le
logement la question éducative et les
impôts alors nous on s'engage sur une
baisse des impôts locaux de 10% sur la
question de la réussite scolaire on a un
vrai sujet là-dessus sur trap il faut
vraiment qu'on ait une stratégie très
efficace pour rehausser le niveau de
dans nos écoles donc il y a tout ce qui
concerne les outils numériques sur
lesquels l'investissement doit être
poussé plus loin sur la question du
logement lol nous le constat qu'on fait
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a une
municipalité qui ne joue pas son rôle
là-dessus et son rôle c'est de faire
appliquer la loi il faut absolument que
la municipalité mette en demeure
systématiquement tous les bailleurs qui
ne respectent pas leurs obligations en
matière d'entretien de réparation de
salubrité la question du logement une
priorité également pour Luc Miserey 52
ans qui représentera le Front de gauche
et souhaite mieux accompagner les
associations de locataires ce qu'il faut
changer fondamentalement c'est les
critères de gestion des bailleurs
sociaux pour pas qu'ils aient fixent les
familles comme ça se passe à l'heure
actuelle les familles sont fixées
partout donc là il y a une vigilance
particulière à avoir Luc misery a été
élu attrape entre 95 et 2001 cet ancien
instituteur milite pour l'emploi voulant
désigner un premier maire adjoint chargé
de ces questions il veut aussi plus de
justice sociale lutter contre les
racismes et les discriminations nous on
propose d'avoir plus d'animateurs de rue
d'éducateurs de rue de médiateurs
sociaux d'éducateur spécialisé mais ça
ça exige des moyens ces moyens là c'est
l'État qui peut nous les octroyer on a
pris la décision de constituer une liste
qui est composée exclusivement de gens
qui habitent à Trappes et qui sont
partis prenantes de la vie locale aussi
bien au niveau associatif que
professionnel pas de parti politique une
politique pour les Trappistes autre
candidature à gauche celle de Mohamed
kameli 38 ans née attrapé il y a fait
toute sa vie ce chef d'entreprise est
militant depuis 91 en 2008 il est
présent en dernière municipale sur la
liste de Dominique Dubuisson conseiller
municipal d'opposition il crée un
collectif après les émeutes de cet été à
Trappes sa volonté donner la parole aux
habitants notre liste est 100% trappiste
moi-même donc je suis né j'ai grandi ici
la majorité des colistiers sont nés à
Trappes donc ils vivent les
problématiques que les citoyens et les
concitoyens vivent au quotidien donc
l'engagement qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui c'est d'amener tous les
citoyens à devenir acteur et non plus
spectateurs des politiques et justement
des tracteur par leur propositions leur
propre culpassion les amener autour
d'une table et créer un réel débat ces
priorités renforcées les dispositifs des
comités de quartier développer le monde
associatif l'accès à l'emploi et un
grand axe de travail sur l'éducation il
n'est normal aujourd'hui que nous
trouvons des enfants déscolarisés à
partir de 13 14 ans qui est dans nos
rues il est impossible il est anormal en
tout cas de voir des enfants qui ne
savent pas lire et écrire à l'entrée en
6e il y a des dysfonctionnements que
nous allons chercher à comprendre enfin
dernière candidature Slimane boussana 42
ans c'est ingénieur de formation
président de l'association qui gère le
collège musulman de 50 ans en Yvelines
trappiste depuis 26 ans se présente pour
la première fois Slimane boussana a
constitué sa liste en trois semaines une
liste qui place au coeur du débat
politique la question de l'islamophobie
réunir un certain nombre où le maximum
en tout cas de voir qui souhaite dire
alt à l'islamophobie et halte à la
discrimination l'effet d'islamophobie
ont augmenté de 57% entre 2011 et 2012
donc dès lors qu'il y a une parole
publique
qui est une parole d'exclusion qui est
une parole de stigmatisation ça se
transforme par la suite en acte en
paroles en fait islamophobe ou en fait
discriminatoire parce que nous ne
limitons pas nos limitons pas à la
question de l'islamophobie nous sommes
aussi pour toutes les discriminations
qui touchent les personnes les plus
fragiles les plus fragiles les personnes
les plus récentes sur le territoire
les roms par exemple Slimane bouchanna
refuse de définir sa liste comme
communautaire il préfère parler de
questions de justice et d'égalité autre
priorité pour lui le logement et
l'emploi et souhaite également plus de
transparence dans la gestion municipale
en 2008 le maire sortant Guy Malandain
avait été élu dès le premier tour avec
près de 55% des voix face à trois autres
listes
et pour conclure cette série de
portraits proposés par la rédaction
direction à présent
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le Front national
va tenter de semer le trouble dans un
duel programmé entre l'Union de la
gauche et l'Union de la Droite une ville
particulièrement observée par les autres
communes de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
d'ici effectivement que sortiront le
plus grand nombre d'éluscitons ensuite à
l'agglomération Anthony Rech il veut
construire une nouvelle dynamique qui
niemontaine investie par le Parti
socialiste Vivien Gasque se lance à 33
ans dans sa première campagne municipale
arrivé sur Montigny il y a deux ans au
quartier du plan de l'église ce
directeur de service technique veut
anticiper la transition énergétique
préserver le commerce de proximité et
surtout créer une cité des cultures le
collège Bergson était le projet phare de
Michel Laugier en 2008 l'idée de de
cette cité c'est qu'elle soit ouverte et
que ce soit pas simplement un équipement
public posez-la et parce qu'il faut
déplacer le conservatoire de musique
mais que en plus ce lieu soit ouvert
qu'il est des espaces publics qui de
pratiquer une activité culturelle et
musicale par exemple au moment de la
fête de la musique on peut tout à fait
imaginer que les musiciens avec un une
cité qui soit ouverte pratique la
musique à l'extérieur un peu à
l'intérieur mis de côté depuis 2008 le
projet du collège Bergson est à nouveau
au centre du programme de Michel logier
fermé en 2007 le maire sortant souhaite
transformer cette ancien collège en pôle
culturel il veut également faire de
l'ancienne école sa main un pôle de la
petite enfance et lui depuis 2001 sur
Montigny et maire depuis 2004 Michel
Laugier veut poursuivre le travail
entamé et conserver le cadre de vie ni
Montin je suis confiant parce que nous
avons un vrai bilan et surtout nous
avons un vrai programme un programme qui
n'est pas fait de phrases qui ne veulent
rien dire ce sont des choses tout à fait
concrètes bien précises et en plus des
choses qui seront finançables donc moi
je suis là pour avoir une action qui
soit menée mais qui soit adaptée aussi
aux besoins
les habitants et surtout au budget de la
ville les électeurs inhi montant auront
à choisir avec une troisième liste celle
du rassemblement bleu marine conduit par
Sylvain Grison
Igny montint depuis 1990 le fondateur de
la course parcourir Montigny a rejoint
le Front national en 2012 après
l'élection présidentielle cet ancien
militaire de 64 ans veut lutter contre
l'hégémonie droite-gauche et appliqué ni
plus ni moins les idées classiques du
parti frontiste sur cette élection
locale ma plus grande quinte aujourd'hui
sur Montigny c'est ce qui se développe
de plus en plus dans mon nombre de
communes en France et en particulier
dans la banlieue parisienne c'est le
comment dirais-je l'immigration on a vu
certains quartiers comme le quartier des
prés comme le quartier du pas du lac
changer de physionomie et c'est
inquiétant parce qu'on est en train de
mettre en application sur Montigny comme
dans d'autres villes de la de la ville
nouvelle
les directives gouvernementales et là
effectivement il y a de quoi s'inquiéter
aux dernières élections 2008 Michel
Laugier avait été élu dès le premier
tour avec plus de 60% des suffrages face
à la candidate socialiste de l'époque
Sandrine Grandgambe
lecture vient demain 18h toujours en
direct sur TVfil avec Anthony Rechal à
la présentation excellente soirée